here is a simple application of the law
of iterated expectations we revisit the
stick breaking example which we have
seen sometime in the past so in this
example we start with a stick that has a
certain length and which we break at the
point that chosen uniformly at random
throughout the length of the stick and
we call the point at which we cut the
stick Capital y so the random variable Y
has a uniform distribution on the
interval from zero to L and is described
by this particular PDF then we take the
piece of the stick that's left and we
break it at a point that's chosen
uniformly over the length of the stick
that's left so the stick that was left
has a length Y and the place at which we
cut it X is chosen uniformly over that
interval so in particular X or rather
the conditional distribution of x given
Y is uniform on that interval so in this
example what is the expected value of X
if I tell you the value of y well given
the value of y the random variable X is
uniform on that range so the expected
value is going to be at the midpoint and
is equal to Y over 2 this is an equality
between numbers for any particular
number little why we have this equality
now let us convert this concrete
equality between numbers to a more
abstract equality between random
variables this object is a random
variable that takes this value whenever
Capital y is little Y so this is an
object that takes the value little Y
over 2 whenever the random variable
capital Y happens to be little Y but
that's the same as the random variable
capital y over 2 this is a random
variable that takes this value whenever
capital y happens to be the same as
little Y so the conditional expectation
the abstract conditional expectation is
a random variable
because its value is determined by the
random variable Capital y and it is this
particular function of the random
variable Capital y and now we can
proceed and calculate the expected value
of X using the law of iterated
expectations the law of iterated
expectations takes this form we have
already calculated what this random
variable is it is the random variable
that's equal to Y over 2 so this is the
same as 1/2 the expected value of Y and
since Y is uniform in the range from 0
to 12 the expected value of y is equal
to L over 2 which gives us an answer of
L over 4 this is the same as the answer
that we got in the past where we
actually found it using the total
expectation theorem the calculations
were exactly the same as what went on
here except that here we carry out the
calculation in a more abstract form and
what is important to appreciate from
this example is the distinction between
these two lines this is an equality
between numbers which is true for any
specific little Y who are as this is an
equality between random variables this
quantity is random and this quantity is
also random meaning that their values
are not known until the experiment is
carried out and the specific value of
capital y is realized